this is the residence of Fred Finchley
he's a family man who enjoys the peace
and quiet of his little home Fred
Finchley has a good job
Freddy nook and his family enjoys their
standard of living his salary keeps up
with the cost of living and he owns some
of those work saving appliances we all
admire so much Finchley always checks to
make sure he gets his money's worth but
after paying his his savings account and
life insurance premiums there never
seems to be enough money left to pay for
that but there's a time for dreaming and
a time for working
so every workday morning sensually joins
the stream of traffic that flows toward
his job as you can see Finchley could
not be collector but he always gets to
work right on
time hey sorry sixty dollars a month
have a cigar thanks for the good work in
truth well uh hey thanks JB for the
cigar and and grace sixty black someone
hey can I use it
sure you can mr. Finchley but how hot
yes what will you do with those extra
dollars there are lots of things you
could do burial it in can in the
backyard for instance but Idol money may
in time depreciate or you could spend it
on a couple of nights out a week with
the wife
it seems like a lot of fun but with this
kind of life you'd appreciate so why not
put your money to work put my money to
work that's right mr. Finchley you can
own a share of American business are
over 1200 companies listed on the New
York Stock Exchange companies which
employ more than 11 million people
produce half of all the goods made in
America and pay about half the nation's
dividends many of these companies have
been paying dividends for 25 years or
longer tycoon neither are most of the
people who own shares in American
business 3 out of 4 of all share owners
are in families which make less than
$10,000 a year the raise was only sixty
dollars a month well the monthly
investment plan pacifically designed for
anyone who wants to invest in common or
preferred stocks on a pay-as-you-go
basis you can $40 up to one thousand
dollars every month or every three
months under MIP so why not the member
firm of the new york stock exchange and
get some practical advice on how to own
a share in america sness and before you
invest investigate yeah invest
just think with 60 bucks a month I cool
just a moment sir if you please you look
like the kind of a picture of the man of
judgment who knows how to invest his
money wisely herb Levesque won't you
step into my office please let me give
you a hot tip of the strictly
confidential
for a limited time only we are offering
two discriminating buyers like yourself
a few shares in a world famous company
with mine in nigeria tasmania somalia
land and brooklyn it's utopia m--
unlimited it grows in the dark small
investment big profit as a special favor
I'll let you have 100 shares for only 40
cents a share that comes to $40 plus of
course twenty dollars for putting you on
to a surefire moneymaker you are now a
man of some hey mr. Finchley there is a
big difference between dealing with a
fly by night operator and a reputable
broker he sit down mr. Finchley first
tell me what are you gonna sell me not a
thing mr. Finchley
as members of the new york stock
exchange we are prepared to be of
service to you a face everyday member
brokers buy ends of thousands of shares
of stock a doctor in Atlanta wants to
buy some stock calmer in spokane wants
to sell his stock in the same company to
get to cash save for a new tractor the
atlanta broker for the buyer and the
spokane broker for the seller speed the
orders to their exchange members on the
floor of the new york stock exchange
when the floor broker representing the
buyer bids the price asked by the floor
broker representing the seller our
transaction is made
when you sell securities on the new york
stock exchange in cash by the buyer
every day millions of dollars of listed
securities are bought and sold on the
new york stock exchange you can check
the price of your stock in a daily
newspaper or by getting the latest
market quotation from a member broker
like myself well-loved how do I get the
facts before i invest before you buy
stock in a company you'd want to know
among other things its record of sales
for previous years what dividends it has
paid and its prospects for the future of
course we can't foretell the future but
we can give you many facts and figures
to help you select a suitable stock how
about this monthly investment plan maybe
i'd want to invest only about fifty
dollars a month well MIP was set up for
people who want to buy stocks on a $50 a
month can build up quite a little nest
egg suppose you take a trial run
imaginary investment route might dock
selling for $100 a share let's say you
invest 50 does each month in a stock
selling for $20 a share at this price
your buys almost two and a half shares
the broker's commission if the price of
your stock dropped don't get discouraged
providing you believe the long-range
price trend will be upward of course you
can sell at any time but you lose on
stock that cost you more than 50 share
in addition you'll have to pay the
broker's commission on the sale to
continue the plan repayment of fifty
dollars buys three and a fraction shares
of stock at fifteen dollars a share at
twenty seven dollars a share if you sell
here you'll have a profit on the shares
that cost you less than twenty seven
dollars your fifty dollar monthly
payment buys one and a fraction shares
of stock at the price of $27
of course the price of a stock can go
down as well as up but with a long-range
monthly investment plan your fifty
dollars a month buys more shares when
the price is low fewer shares when the
price is high to every doubt the price
of all the stock you purchase you can
quit the plan at any time mr. Finchley
and take the shares you have purchased
but the idea of the monthly investment
plan is to invest every month on a
long-range basis in the stock of a
company that you think will have good
earnings and pay dividends take for
example a company whose stock is selling
at $20 a share if that company over the
past year paid out $1 a share the
dividend yield comes to 5 percent you
can keep the cash or if you wish the
dividends can be automatically
reinvested for you now the investment
route you're traveling is a good one
because the stock has paid satisfactory
dividends and even with its ups and
downs the long-range price trend has
been upwards hmm looks pretty good thank
you but before I invest i'm going to
study the facts myself
that's right mr. Finchley all investors
should study the facts carefully before
they buy any stock and remember the
monthly investment plan is designed
especially for people who want to invest
as little as forty or fifty dollars as
well as for those who want to invest up
to one thousand dollars every month or
every three months there are many
promising investment routes to travel
many companies whose stocks are listed
on the new york stock exchange have
helped to build our rising standard of
living by constantly creating new job
services and products therefore mr.
Finchley and all those who can assume
the risk of seeking dividends and
profits can put their dollars to work by
owning their share of American business
through the monthly investment plan
you